[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département
[Musique]
c'est parti pour la 21e édition du
challenge des créateurs
un concours qui valorise les
responsables d'entreprises locales qui
ont su créer leur activité
cette catégorie seront récompensés par
le département et de réseaux point
chance les inscriptions sont ouvertes
jusqu'au 17 septembre sur le
www.defirh.fr 4 point fr on le sait il
ya beaucoup de réunionnais qui ont des
projets mais qui n'osent pas aller vers
ce challenge et créateurs au contraire
le charger créateur ça vous permet
d'être avec d'autres jeunes ou moins
jeunes qui ont des projets et souvent
cette rencontre avec tous ceux qui ont
des projets et qui voue au challenge des
créateurs
ça permet aussi de faire des liens de
tisser des liens et peut-être des liens
qui pourront dynamiser le projet qu'ils
ont et le département est là justement
pour créer cette énergie pour créer
cette dynamique des repas équilibrés
réalisé avec des produits pays et qui
plus est issu à 90% de l'agriculture
biologique
c'est l'une des actions menées dans les
collèges dans le cadre du projet
nutrition santé
un travail participatif entre les
collégiens l'équipe éducative et les
responsables des filières locales
l'objectif étant de sensibiliser les
jeunes aux dangers du diabète et à la
nécessité d'avoir une alimentation saine
et équilibrée mais davantage de sang sur
les différents aliments
en peine d'où viennent les produits
qu'ils consomment et comme à ce qu'on
fait pour avoir une alimentation
équilibrée la nécessité de consommer
l'eau de consommer des produits locaux
et des produits de qualité
on a également l'intervention de la
filière volaille pays donc on a un
éleveur qui est par un établissement qui
vient également et on a un soutien de la
ribère aujourd'hui les enfants ne
connaissent pas qu'est ce qu'un produit
bio pourquoi le fait-on essaris qu'on
leur donne à manger
comment ça a été tellement sympa
aujourd'hui l'important c'est de leur
montrer pourquoi le faire et comment le
faire
est ce que ça nous apporte
affronter un manteau et le bénin le
président du département s'est rendu à
l'atelier des filles pour rencontrer les
acteurs de la filière de transformation
du bois de goyavier une quarantaine
d'agents travaillent ici à transformer
ses gaules est récolté dans les forêts
départementaux domaniale une véritable
filière d'exploitation et d'insertion je
vais à la rencontre des agents du
département et ce matin effectivement je
suis ici d'ancrage au sein de la filière
bois de goyavier avec les agents du
département qui travaillent ce bois
magnifique qu'est le bois de goyavier on
a fait d'une peste végétale un produit
remarquable à produits mobiliers
remarquable je salue le travail réalisé
ici fait les réalisations de demand les
tabourets des chaises des
déjà ce soir
mohammad les serviettes le dessus
tout ce qui le bonus de cette semaine
c'est une traversée des trois cirques de
la réunion découvrir cilaos mafate et
salazie à pied et en drones un voyage en
immersion avec les images de la course
de la cima saron dans votre émission
terre de travail
non
[Musique]